What can shuck corn, light cigarettes, and change light bulbs?
The answer, Chinese farmer Wu Yulu's robots.
Wu's five 'sons', as they are known in the village on the outskirts of Beijing,...
...each have a special skill.
One can dance, one can jump, and another can run and chase away curious children.
There's also a robot that can walk on walls and ceilings.
But Wu's newest creation is the 'Darling' because it can do housework.
The meter - high gadget is a concoction of gears and cables wrapped in a flowery green skirt.
Guided by remote control, the robot can pick up things and carry them around,...
...click on a lighter and screwing light bulbs and a myriad of menial household tasks.
The creator of the robot is a 41 - year - old farmer who never finished primary school...
...but has made more than 20 machines since 1995.
Wu is regarded by his neighbors and their children as the man with many interesting toys in his house.
But Wu has great faith in his creative aspirations and hopes his gadgets will benefit society.